I wanna I wanna talk about solving the
problem here by pulling up this here
website my son hunter.com oh boy I want
to start by saying this first just for
those that aren't familiar this is a
movie called my son Hunter and it's
about the bidens and I want to say
culture is everything politics is
Downstream from culture culture
influences culture inspires and cultures
decide whether or not a law truly stands
on the books for instance there are old
laws like you can't put a pie on a
windowsill on Tuesday because it
attracts wild animals and their school
kids out but no one enforces that law
there's books called like wacky laws and
they're like did you know that you can't
do it no really you can't take a bath on
Sundays in Massachusetts or whatever but
I want a copy of this book there's a
bunch of them actually they're funny and
those those laws are never repealed the
issue is our culture changed and we
decided okay we're not going to arrest
anybody for that anymore anymore I'm
pretty sure sodomy is still illegal in a
bunch of places as well no cop is going
to kick your door in because they think
two guys are hooking they're like we're
not doing that because culture but if we
were a Theocratic fascist country they
would be kicking the door and saying
it's a law in the books right building
culture is the most important thing we
can do and that's why I think the movie
you guys are doing is is so important do
you want to explain what the movie is
who's in it what's it about well it's my
son Hunter and it's based on the uh not
only the laptops and the information
they like Peter schweitzer's book and
stuff that John Solomon did and all the
Articles uh at infinitum about the
hunter Biden laptop it's also I I looked
at beautiful things his autobiography to
get a mindset of him even though Hunters
Hunters oh no oh no he writes about
doing crack and all that you know this
is where Robert differs from Hunters
Robert's actually red Hunter's biography
Hunter Hunter's reading and he's like
what I wanted to do was because we have
all the of course the the sizzle of of
of the corruption of the Ukrainian deals
of the Russian mafia deals of the the
Chinese spy Chief and the tons of deals
he made with the Chinese flying uh you
got them flying to China together on Air
Force two no I don't have that but it's
implied you'll see and
in a different way and it's it's very
funny
I I mean I should tell you I have Joe
with a Superman cape on for one second
when he when he visits the Chinese and
you hear that
yeah and Hunter goes dad daddy and now
the deals start to happen but uh so it's
all told Through The Eyes of a a 25 year
old uh left-wing activist who is a
stripper to pay for her college
education
and she meets up with Hunter a
relationships a relationship starts a
bouncer from the strip joint is put with
them when they go to the Chateau Mar Mo
to have this big party uh who's a actor
who is a soccer player of great face
Franklin uh Adelaide a Nigerian soccer
player and he's the one who says uh
Kitty I'm the black face of white
supremacy and he's the one that
navigates her through the internet to
find out when she realizes this is Joe
Biden's son my life just got much more
interesting I want to go back to the
website real quick so you uh so I was
obviously directed by Robert you've got
Lawrence Fox John James Gina Carano and
Emily uh kovich goyovic there you go wow
I totally butchered that uh Emma sorry
Emma goyevic uh so you got a bunch of
great people in here and uh you yourself
for i i a lot of people are already
chatting they know who you are they're
commenting on all the shows you've been
in they're all like they all recognize
you from Halo oh yeah
so I mean you're you're like you're a
big Hollywood guy and you're now you
know you you left you went to Florida
now you're doing a movie that is very
much exposing the Biden family I have to
imagine a lot of your old friends are
probably not happy
well you know if they're real friends
you know look at I have friends of mine
that absolutely left wing and it's what
it is I say to them okay I have lots of
good friends that are name actors that
are
quiet conservatives that have frightened
about canceling and everything else in
their careers so there's a different
kind of a thing people that might have
uh so but um
we have to become culture Warriors
yes as you said we have to we can't
worry about that because then we leave
them to do the narrative and we get left
out because the emotion of culture is
what the young minds can respond to and
what can move people have you watched
the show the boys no not yet I think
it's fantastic it is a little cringe
have you seen it Alex I'm aware of it I
haven't seen it I don't even know about
it aware of it and I know all the memes
nobody nobody nobody has watched it uh
so it's basically it's like the DC it's
like DC's Justice League but if they're
real people right and so you end up with
homelander right he's like Superman he's
a narcissist he's a sociopath he wants
everyone to love him and then you know
all of these characters are basically
flawed celebrity types of superpowers
and that's kind of the show explores and
then there's government cover-ups
because a superheroes accidentally kill
people all the time you know it's
interesting they've taken this turn in
the show where they've made Superman
into Trump they've made homelander
basically Trump and this is the
importance of culture in the show the
good guys are like yo they're going on
TV and lying about what's going on and
there's like a fake Tucker Carlson and
then homelander clearly is lying about
things and then they say they're they're
clearly making him be Trump then they're
saying he's lying and show you fictional
situations where he knows he's lying too
they're trying to to set your your
preconceptions as to what's happening in
the world because they know there are
low information dumb people who are
going to see Trump and go he he's lying
too oh I saw that on TV and people might
you know people who watch the show might
might give the benefit of the doubt to
the average person but I'm telling you
that level of influence does work oh it
does people think they're Geniuses for
making that connection too yeah and so
what what you need to dress like Trump
here's what you do you make a show that
is not political like the boys but then
you make a loop put a message in the
ravioli exactly put a message
yes that's what I did with the film I've
got an important question and it has to
be a good ravioli and extremely tasty
cheese and Spanish yeah mushroom you
could have you could have a vegetarian
you can have ricotta mushroom but it has
to be a beautiful sauce oh yeah yeah
do you guys think uh Hunter is going to
watch it I think so because this is like
again
The Wolf of Wall Street and friends of
mine in Hollywood you talked about some
of the Hollywood franches you know
country is like a Counter Culture hero
yeah drug abuse of the women and the
Chateau and guys you should say you know
I was at the Chateau mama when he was
partying what a wild scene that was let
me tell you there's a read on hunter
that he's actually the only cool
Democrat
so if you didn't know what he does it's
true
let's take that oh my gosh
people send him tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands we don't know who
these people are his Arts crap I mean
and Robert does an incredible job
satirizing it in the movie but we don't
it's just an easy way to get this none
of us thought of that none of us are
that smart he's the one who's cutting
all the deals for that you've just blown
my mind maybe he realizes like my dad's
been bullshitting his whole life
when he said Hunter's the smartest guy
he knows
serious this is this is he wasn't on
crack you'll see it you'll see in the
film about that we we this goes there in
the film
the girl figures it out
um
when she's having a conversation with
him that and and this is what makes it
again a very interesting uh film to me
well is that you can't even when I was
researching this a a actress friend of
mine said you know Hunter rented a uh
Airbnb from my friend
it was a laptop and another
there was a backpack and another laptop
there this guy was leaving stuff all
over the place while he was getting high
every 15 minutes dealing with the
highest people in China and everywhere
else so like cracked out of his mind and
he's like well pays off but here's my
laptop
no one the supposition Tim is
are the laptops left on purpose yeah
yeah or what and then he hates his dad
and he's just like why can't I just lose
him the election already
this is uh yeah we don't go there but we
go there but you do have Biden sniffing
children right no no no no he sniffs of
the people there's a lot he says other
people
yeah I didn't want to tell you I'll tell
you what I think I think I think uh Joe
Biden is a pedophile and I think he
abused Hunter
that may or may not be I don't want to
watch the film please we'll check it out
the film that I don't want to go into
that because I didn't want to again I
wanted because
there are certain there's enough there
there's enough there enough red meat
there I wanted to make people that were
in the middle want to watch this film
because it's a good picture
while supplying the story and the truth
what we think allegedly happened let's
talk about Corn Pop oh yeah you know
what I think I think Joe Biden
besmirched the good name of corn
absolutely because if you listen to his
story what did he say the kids were
rubbing my legs do you remember this
he'd be like the kids are rubbing my
legs and the hair would curl and people
have commented someone super chatted
what if Corn Pop was a good guy he was
protecting the kids protecting the kids
from a creepy yeah I saw that I believe
it I really do yeah and Joe's telling
this nonsense story about he called him
Esther or whatever and the guy had a
knife yeah I think he like I was in a
rain barrel and it was getting rusty and
then you bang it up get them all rusty
yeah we can't miss those I think Joe
Biden was at the pool with a bunch of
little kids being a creep and Corn Pop
was like yo you need to get out of here
and he was like come on man dude someone
made a cartoon where Joe talks about the
kids grabbing his legs they animated it
and it's just so much you've seen it oh
yeah I love it
his legs what is this guy yeah they're
standing up they turn blonde in the sun
he says the stuff out loud also in that
speech he called black children roaches
it was this he calls black children
roaches in the speech no one's caught
this it is the most racist comment I've
ever heard in my life period this wasn't
this wasn't 1969. this wasn't
1840. this was 2017. so what in what
context he was talking about the kids at
the pool he says I know how to deal with
roaches it's the craziest thing when you
play it back now you're gonna freak out
it's unbelievable and he says it in this
thing which is he he is a he there's
definitely a pervy side as I think he
abused Hunter I I I thought about how
does the son of someone so prominent be
a crack addict who's who's got these
weird perversions and I'm like something
happened to him he was traumatized then
you look at his Dad sniffing and groping
children and I'm like I think I know
where this is going yeah and everyone
says like oh if that were happening it
would come out you know Joe Biden's a
powerful man there would be people
watching but no that's precisely why
something like that would never come out
people know if you are crazy enough to
abuse children you'd be crazy enough to
kill people who were going to talk about
it I think there's a lot there for me
there's enough there without making that
supposition and when you see the film
there's enough there to say what let it
happen let people make their own
decision because that then it doesn't it
I I think sometimes it doesn't help us
bring people into the tent because let
them say oh my God make this a position
and let them come up I'm not saying I
know for sure about anything but just
the idea that like if the elites are
abusing children it would come out for
sure like no they would have so many
methods of coverage Epstein yeah exactly
people didn't believe that it was too
crazy when Alex Jones was talking about
they're like he's crazy there's no way
that's happening did you see the trial
where the lawyer asks Jones and he's
like so you believe that you know
Epstein or no he's like you believe that
there's a cabal of like Elites that are
trafficking children and he goes you
mean like what Epstein did with the
clintons
people made a thug life video where the
sunglasses come on yeah it was wild
wasn't there something weird and Biden's
daughter's diary yes showering together
but there's a bigger question why did
the FBI go after a lost diary yeah she's
a private citizen right she's not in
government and it wasn't legit right is
Russian disinfo too right that wasn't a
real vir right why was it to protect the
incontinence
I don't know but what I what I can say
is something is wrong when the FBI says
a Diary of a private citizen is of
National Security a little girl a little
girl's diary well I mean how old was she
when she wrote it because I thought it
was like 11 or 14 or something I don't
know so this is just a a 50 cent piece
of paper
and the FBI had to get it well so now
you gotta Wonder nothing else to do I
mean she wrote about taking showers with
Joe right there was something alluded to
that and she said probably inappropriate
or something like that yeah it was that
was again alluded to I don't know I
didn't read that I'm just the hearsay of
it there was things to that your
audience can tweet us and or remember
when uh Joe broke his foot or whatever
because the dog in the shower or
something like that yeah that was
unbelievable what is going on you know
what what's interesting about this movie
and Tim you've been talking about this a
lot this week on your show about how you
gotta start with the art and this is
what really Drew Us in at Breitbart
we've always wanted to distribute movies
and get into this entertainment business
to lure people into your right-wing
World well I I will say it flat out yes
absolutely but you don't do it just by
starting with the politics and then you
try to see if we can put something
together no you start with the
Aesthetics you take Robert who's being
had a byline of Breitbart since 2009
knew Andrew were friends but he travels
the world performing Frank Sinatra songs
he's made movies in the past he's a
household name in a household face for
his acting career that's the type of guy
we want to see make a movie and the
movie is hilarious it is so many facts
in it it's so exciting to watch it is it
hits you in the face it's like a fever
dream at times there's really good
looking people in it it's really fun and
then also it does layer in all of that
stuff that if you're not listening to a
show like this or reading Breitbart or
listening to our shows then you're not
getting that information and the same
way came with what you're doing through
music which is you're just making music
I loved when you read earlier this week
and I'm going to flatter you a little
bit but it was so good you were reading
Super Chat and someone hating on on your
music and and you said they were reading
something like it was the worst song
they ever heard and you said well maybe
it is I don't know I made a song you're
very honest about it but I made a song I
put it out let's let people evaluate it
I love that approach so much I think
Andrew would have loved that approach
because you you create the art let the
art be what it is and let people talk
about it let people discuss it Let The
Daily Beast try to cancel you over it do
that that's what Robert promoted for me
exactly right I'll say it now that it's
Thursday and this is the last day I
didn't want to say anything when we
launched but all of these lefties
attacking the song We're pumping the
numbers tremendously and but they really
were they were posting it there's like
17 posts on Reddit we have we have an
app that tracks social posts for all of
our content yeah and then I'm just like
watching them go nuts rag on the song
and I'm like
95 thumbs up on the people who've
watched it and all they're doing with
hating on it is sharing the video and
it's funny because I was talking to a
friend earlier and I mentioned how The
Daily Beast said this of of me that I'm
trying to lure people in the right-wing
world and he was saying like they need
something to to fight against and I was
like they need to hate it because it's
their thing to do like otherwise what do
they have to talk about there's nothing
right so they create an enemy they say
they hate it but the reality is They
Don't Really Care can I ask you people
are checking out your music and I'm
sorry Robert I'm so this is the thing
I'm most passionate about people are
checking out your music because of this
stuff and they're realizing it's good
they're gonna check out this film
because they read articles like like the
guardian that wrote uh that wrote guys
stop trying to make Hunter Biden
conspiracy theories happen that's a
direct line from they haven't seen the
movie and they're already trying to
cancel it good music is subjective we
were listening to the Billboard Hot 100.
so all these lefties come out and
they're like this music is dated it's
too unless lizzo makes it then it's
always good no matter what as soon as I
was doing it so they said it's dated and
I'm like Kate Bush is number five on the
Billboard Hot 100. it's like what does
data even mean yes but um so we started
listening and we started playing the
song sunroof it came so we're listening
to the radio like the streaming radio in
the car and sunroof by Nikki your came
on and it is a teeny bop
sunroof or something like that and I was
like is this what they want is this what
they want me to do I'll do it I swear
we're gonna make a song called is this
what you want and it's going to be pop
and we're going to be bopping around at
a club and the lyrics are gonna be as
vapid and as boring as possible and I'm
like no look man good music is
subjective some people think Zeppelin
was the epitome of good music some
people think the Beatles were some
people think it's CCR some people think
nah man the 90s the 2000s the 2010s
everybody has their taste and they're
allowed to have it don't know don't care
I like some music I don't like other
music a lot of people really love
Nickelback not for me but hey they were
a number one for four weeks in a row
that is an amazing feat so good for them
if I put out a song it's because I write
music and not everybody has to like it
right and I and it is what it is so I
just want to say on this I thought we'd
get like a hundred a couple a couple
hundred thousand hits on it it's at like
a million something in on the streaming
services we're a couple like a hundred
plus thousand or whatever uh the sales I
think are over 10K or something like
that and then I'm like oh that's really
cool man I really appreciate that people
are supporting us if if a hundred people
liked the music I'd say okay we've put
out cast castle and we've gotten a
certain amount of fans for it we put out
Tails from the inverted world we got
some fans for it chicken cities got fans
none of these things are like Time
Magazine front page uh you know content
and no one cared about any of those
things but this song actually took off
and people liked it and they reacted
with an inverse reaction of if people
are liking it we have to hate it with an
equal amount of force
we say right wing a lot and
I think they might say okay what is
right wing
you know the definition of right wing
and left to me I love this country my
grandmother
my grandparents came from Sicily in
Naples the New York Times said the
Italian was lower and dirty than the
Negro in 1906. there were 18 in 1886
there were more lynchings of Italians
than anybody else 12 15 Sicilians were
lynched in New Orleans in 1886.
now
when you say right wing and you say they
came to this country their first they
were speaking Italian my first language
was listening to Italian but they said
in the home speak of the English
raise the flag my grandfather came and
went into the U.S infantry critically
World War One critically wounded twice
my dad World War II my uncle's the
Battle of midways my dad's ship was
torpedoed he was in the water three days
every Memorial Day veterans day the flag
was raised he put on his Navy uniform
there was a patriotic
in the air
we loved our country there was something
in the air
and they have taken it away and that's
not right wing
we're not right-wing we're Americans
there should be no left and right there
should be Americans and the whole idea
of America First this is what we have to
keep bringing up the idea that there was
a man and I want to bring him up quickly
William Harvey Carney you've got Black
History Month William Harvey Carney was
a was a a black slave
who fought in the Civil War for the for
the for the for the Union
the guys holding the American flag was
shot up and the flag was about to hit
the ground and he picked it up before it
hit the ground and he marched with the
flag and he got critically wounded
himself several times he got the safety
he gave the flag off he said the old
flag never hit the ground boys he then
became in the
1870s and 80s he became part of the
first post office postmaster and got the
Medal of Honor in 1903 has Black History
Month ever talked about William Harvey
Carney no do you know the The Legend of
the uh the American national anthem How
It Was Written
when he sang uh the bombs bursting in
air gave proof of the night the flag was
still there the idea was that you know
he's on this ship yes and the American
flag was the fort was being bombarded
and every time a bomb would explode the
flag would be illuminated and what was
happening was every time damage would be
taken the flag would go down someone
would run up and prop it up and then die
holding it and in the morning when they
came back seeing the flag there it was
the corpses of the soldiers who refused
to let it fall who had kept it up in the
end now that's probably a legend but
it's a brutal story of like refusing to
let the flag fall well that was William
Harvey Kearney now we got this guy
Kaepernick kneeling and people spitting
on the flag and this is desecrating
America look at every country in the
history of civilization has gone through
difficulties they've had slaves they've
had uh Wars they've had everything are
we going to go back to the beginning of
time and go into Egypt and Saudi Arabia
and uh Wales everywhere so you got to
stop the nonsense what's going on in our
politicians are feeding into it we're
American
this is a great country we have freedom
we're blessed with a country not right
wing it's not right wing it's not alt
right it's not left I mean let it's
Marxist and America First in Freedom
here's what we have
we have traditionally in this country a
left and a right at some point in this
blob of left and right-wing politics a a
budding occurred and a blob of the left
flop schlapped off and grew and became
its own political sphere that calls
itself the left but there is still a
left and a right if Ben Shapiro and I
were to sit down and talk hard policies
I would be left of him and we would
disagree on many things and we would
agree on certain facts and studies but
our opinions on how they should be
handled be slightly different because
there's a left and a right traditionally
in this country but this weird cell
that's been growing and and expanding
that believes it is the left is actually
just a cult they're not left what about
giving a child a sex change is
inherently a left-wing policy position
it's not it is an ideological position
but they call it the left and that's why
everyone else's right wing that's why
they say Tim pulls a far-right YouTuber
it's like bro I'm like pro-progressive
tax and pro-choice but that's right wing
now because it's expanding and its
sphere of influence is expanding however
I do think it is it has begun to lose
the big news that that uh came out
earlier or the other day was that
Gutfeld has surpassed Colbert in the
writings now a lot of people are going
to act like that's no big deal on the
left they don't want to admit that
they're losing but when late night you
know the night late night show whatever
things are called are now less relevant
than a cable news channel that started
in the 90s you are losing your cultural
influence and that matters that means we
are winning yes well they they have
denied look they come out of Los Angeles
in New York these talk show guys and you
got the Cobra guy you've got the other
two guys
and they refused to talk about
the epidemic of homelessness and crime
in those cities it's astounding to me
they'll talk about everything else but
they won't say in their own backyard
because the elites don't give a red look
at the when you go on to a movie set
and we were talking about this earlier
yeah with somebody with uh Sean Spicer
actually sure when I go into movie sets
the crew they'll be doing the makeup or
the hair or the Kyle putting the lights
or the micro game in thank you we're
with you the crew the workers
the people that are running this country
but there's a comic that shows a man
burning a woman at the stake and he says
just so you know I agree with everything
you said right and that's what it is
these are the you know what I I there's
I can respect to a certain degree that
people are are are are struggling and
stuck but it really is not a compliment
for someone to whisper I agree with you
yeah no no I hear you I hear you but
they're there so we have to give them
the courage we have to find out how to
inspire them to speak up culturally to
have these cultural Warriors we have to
speak of this is what I've had a big
argument with a very close friend of
mine like a brother
I won't mention the name I won't mention
what it was about he has a some platform
and he's had people on but he won't have
me on because I'm a it would expose it
would expose the the thing think about
that and so I said but but you agree
with me he goes I know I said but unless
we all start to speak up
what you're talking about is gonna we're
gonna be lost
we've got to take they've got a whole
lot of emotional reasons to hate the
left you know these people have kept
them away from their families through
all the covid stuff gas prices people
getting fired from their jobs it's been
horrific for people but they don't have
a whole lot of emotional reasons to love
the right Trump gave people that for a
bit he was a obviously this big populist
voice well it was about America yeah he
was giving us America but he would amp
people up emotionally right and this is
something I was talking about a year ago
where I was saying you know feelings
don't care about your facts we've been
saying it the wrong way this whole time
I'm so with you on that feelings
motivate people you tell us someone's
kid falls off about you and you tell
them they have one one out of 100 chance
of saving them they're gonna jump in
every time because they love their kid
they're not going to be motivated by the
numbers you give them and that's why I
love being that's like a bunch of
artists yeah I don't think I'd see this
I'll tell you a story right there's
there's a crazy story that was actually
not that long ago where a guy was at the
uh Yosemite I think or the other where
where's the hot springs at is that
Yellowstone yeah Yellowstone Yellowstone
and so he opens his car and his dog
jumps out and runs full speed towards
the hot spring and he yells at it no
stop and it won't listen he runs after
it the dog jumps in the hot spring and
starts screaming so he takes his shirt
off and they tell him you can't go in
and he's and he's like like hell I can't
and he jumps in and immediately goes
help ugh they pull him out he dies oh he
didn't care that he was going to jump
into a boiling vet his dog was already
dead but he loved his dog and didn't
think twice yeah there's another story
of a guy who there's a video of this I
think he runs up to his house on fire
and the fire department's there and he
runs up and then the firefighters are
yelling at him and then he like just
runs past him and runs out with two dogs
yeah people are motivated by them all
day it was an article there was an
article and I wrote an article in the
Washington Times
our pets are family too and it was about
and this was in the 80s when there was a
thing with there were street muggers
that mugged an old couple
beat up the woman took their money
hurt them
and my supposition was and then this was
in one spot and this the passerbys did
nothing
there was another in DC where there was
someone on the roof on a Ledge and the
people down to stay stay help them help
them let's get him help what's the
difference in the scenarios one was
human being the other on the ledge was a
dog wow really so I said that if these
kids that mug these women never had an
animal to love and I said our Animals
help us be more human that's so true in
a certain way and I said and this was in
the 80s I wrote this on the Washington
Times
I mean yeah I wrote it in the 90s but
how interesting is that that we
you know that story going back to you
that the guy ran in for his dogs I mean
can I go to the bathroom
you don't gotta ask you just go and do
it
you have to put your hand up first
yeah and then actually Lydia has to give
you the permission yeah that's true I do
have to give you yeah you need a pass
also because there's a pass and so but I
think that I'm a little black build on
this too because I think that it's too
late to just sit around and Whisper to
Robert when Robert's your makeup chair
it's just that those days are over yeah
uh we need people to be outspoken and
you don't have to be mean about it you
don't have to be uh it's if that's not
your voice find your voice but you do
have to be out there and be vocal and
say actually I don't think the lockdowns
are that great I don't think we should
amass kids all that much just start with
something basic just start with well you
know I liked abortion when it was safe
legal and rare why is it third trimester
fourth trimester like what why yeah post
birth just start with something like
that and see how you received but not
even that I said you don't even need to
say anything other than
oh I don't know that sounds kind of
weird that's it someone comes to you and
they say something like right you know I
I think we should be giving children sex
changes to go oh I don't know that
sounds a little extreme that's it yes
and they'll say are you trying to be
like I have no idea what you're talking
about dude I just right yeah I'm
confused just chemical castration you're
not gonna go that far like I thought I
was a dog when I was five yeah really
talking about time for surgery Lauren
yeah
all right before we go to super Jazz can
I say because we've been having this
conversation myself and my husband
because I made the supposition that
facts do care about your feelings or
feelings don't care about your facts yes
this is something that bench bear talks
about a lot facts don't care about your
feelings I think this is why the right
is losing it's because they ignore the
fact that feelings exist and are very
important because like you're talking
about how people jump into the freaking
hot springs after their dogs we had a
dog die this year and I think Robert's
right that it really makes people more
human to have to care deeply about a
creature like that Ben Shapiro is wrong
he's wrong he is wrong do care about
your feelings very
so we people have said facts don't care
about your feelings yes but feelings
don't care about your facts but facts
are manufactured by People based on
their emotions and I don't mean literal
literally I mean in the world of
post-modernism they claim facts but
they're really fabricating they're using
sophistry to assert what they claim is a
fact when it's not so when you get them
coming out saying Donald Trump staged an
Insurrection they would tell you it's a
fact and it's based on their feelings
yes so people believe the facts quote
unquote facts they're receiving are true
when in fact they're just manipulations
of emotion we just watched a whole
speech that was pure feeling and emotion
and platitudes presented as these are
the facts this is what's going on in our
country all violence violence violence
finally said violence like six times
what because one Trump supporter got
killed by law enforcement of January the
sixth like that's it like that's the
basis
three years of violence what the
violence was in the streets it's not in
Portland they just shot and killed a guy
I mean it's it's they they they attacked
an old man in a van thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there